This brings us to the end
of our foundations lesson.
Our goal here has been to
give you a solid basis for
studying machine learning.
You now know where machine
learning came from and
where it sits in the broader
family of artificial intelligence.
You now know the three major types of
machine learning that we'll cover,
supervised, unsupervised,
and reinforcement learning.
You now know some of the applications of
machine learning like robotics, trading,
and health care, and finally, you now
know some of the basics behind model
building and machine learning,
like classification and regression.
Next, we'll move on to model
building in more detail.
I hope you're excited to get started.